ce sont des orfèvres de l'aéronautique
ils sont intégrateurs électronique
câbleur ou encore technicien polyvalent
au total 25 personnes sont employées
dans ses ateliers de la société bauwen
jacques loupé cli implantée à trappes
on travaille soit sur system système
antennes est en fait effectivement sur
des sur des produits qui v sont montés
sur l'aéronef
en fait ça ces appareils qui permettent
de communiquer soit avec une un émetteur
qui est situé soit en vols soit au sol
télécommunications et antennes pour
l'aéronautique la spécialité de cette
société en pleine croissance de son
activité elle recherche des nouveaux
collaborateurs notamment dans la
conception de câbles et l'intégration
électronique
il ya de la coupe de câbles et du
raccordement
donc il faut souder des connecteurs sur
les prises bien spécifiques
alors ici nous avons des cartes à
intégrer donc nous avons des cartes
vierges avec mise de composants il faut
connaître savoir soudé et une bonne
expérience si dans les composants savoir
lire et des chiffres eux aussi les plans
après la production vient une phase de
contrôle notamment pour les antennes ces
voix recette fonctionne ces voix se
répondent aux caractéristiques demandées
par les clients c'est voir si l'entamé
correctement assemblé et intégré que
tout se passe bien les post
d'intégrateur électronique et de câbleur
sont à pourvoir dès à présent